this is a phenomenal that this book is
here how like and you've been talking
about it for a while now so how are you
feeling about it now like what's your
relationship with
the book what you've written
how are you feeling oh i alternate
between thrilled out of my mind and
kind of freaked out going oh my god did
i really say that
moments where i
feel like i may have divulged too much
but then other moments i go what the
hell hey i'm 70. i did it what am i
gonna do cover it up forever you know
well when you approach the idea of
writing the stories about your own life
i i find it so fascinating because
you do have to have a lot of courage to
say okay
this part that you know people think
they know now they're gonna know this
part that i've never told anyone
now they're gonna know like what at what
point did you say to yourself okay you
know what it's time for me to do this
and why
i've been thinking about it for really
like 15 years i started
writing little notes and
you know i remember something and i
jotted down but i have had friends tell
me for my whole life you have got to
write your life story you know i tell
them something that i did and they'd go
you have to write your life story so
i kept fooling around forever not really
doing it until
finally the pandemic happened
and i actually had time to really sit
down
and really do the work that it took
it takes a lot of work oh my god i don't
know if i would have done it if i don't
know how hard it is
um
everybody wanted me to get a ghostwriter
and i just did not want to do that i
really wanted to tell it in my own words
even though it may not be as well
written as it would have been with a
ghostwriter i just wanted my own voice
and personality to come through you know
i read a lot of autobiographies and i
can always tell when it's a ghostwriter
versus when it's the real person
mm-hmm and it absolutely does come
through as your voice and i think the
people that have been following you in
your career for a long time
100 appreciate
that it's
all of this coming straight from you and
one of the wonderful things that's come
out of it is um
you know you revealing that you've been
with t with your partner
for years and years now what has been
the the reaction from your lgbtq fans
they have been fantastic they have been
wonderful i mean
i'm worried about them because
i've always had a big lgbtq fan base and
i worried that they would think i was a
hypocrite
and had been lying to them i never lied
about it but i lied
uh by omission you know i didn't tell
anybody
but i have always
uh
tried very hard to keep my private life
private because elvira is elvira she's a
character what i do
in my personal life should not affect my
character even when i was married to a
man for 25 years i didn't
i never told people i was married i mean
they'd find out
you know this way or that but i never
told them because they don't want no
elvira's at home changing baby diapers
you know they really don't
i tried to protect the character and and
you know make her seem like the straight
horn dog that she is
so um did the same thing when i was a
my relationship now with my partner
i just didn't want it to affect elvira
she's my livelihood my brand
what was the discussion like between the
two of you when you decided you were
going to
put that in the book
it was good and bad she's she's happy
about it she's a little freaked out
she's a very private person
and
they're kind of shy she doesn't really
like being all over the media
but we were both ready to just stop
living this secret it's creepy and now i
mean keeping these secrets inside give
you a gas you know it's just not good
i mean it really is it takes a lot of
energy to do that and i don't think it's
a good thing to keep any secrets um
hidden really ultimately um
danny trejo who's a friend of mine and
just wrote his memoir
said um
you're only as sick as your secrets and
that i think that's kind of true
well it feels really good for her i
think now at this point
she's a little freaked out about it but
she's uh
liking the fact that we can
be together in public and
not
hide it you know
yeah one of one of the big
stories that you've revealed in here you
know speaking of secrets uh
you know you talk about how the metoo
movement helped you feel confident
enough to talk about your experience
with wilt chamberlain and your your
sexual assaults what was it
what was this one particular moment
where you
thought to yourself
oh my god
i've got to talk about this now like if
i'm going to be if there's a secret
that's going to keep me sick i need to
do something about it
yeah i i thought about for years and
years and never told anybody my
ex-husband
um
but i never talked about it to anybody
and i
just decided
after the mewtwo movement started
happening that this was the um
time to bring it out um it was
i kept feeling like a victim like i did
something wrong and i didn't do anything
wrong he did something wrong
and i want other victims of sexual
assault
to
know that there are other people out
there who have been through
similar situations
and lived through it and
still
made a career for themselves and made a
livelihood for themselves and it's not
the end of the road when that happens
you know
[Music]
yeah absolutely and it's
but it's like you said it's
it's a way i think
in what you've done here too is
inspiring people to
feel confident in in owning their story
telling their story and and again not
being becoming sick by it right
yeah i mean i really hope honestly that
my
biggest hope for this book is that
it
makes other people feel like
despite their
shortcomings whatever may have happened
to them in their life as a child
as an adult
it doesn't mean that's the end of your
life it means that you can pick yourself
back up and
begin again
um and i hope i hope that it will give
you know some
help help to other women and girls and
then
men you know
um
that that life is not over when these
things happen to you and and hopefully
you can overcome them i say in the end
of the book um
um may your scars become your blessings
and i meant that for me literally
because 35 of my body is skin grafted
and i felt like i was able to turn it
into something that that still worked
for me despite that
um
one thing other people will too
one thing that really comes through in
uh in your stories
is just this
just this constant thirst that you had
for life and experience
and
seeing new things and discovering
yourself when you think back to your
your teenage days and the experiences
that you've had like uh
you're what you call your like junior
groupie days what do you think of when
you look back on that how do you
what do you think of when you look back
at the time in your life
well
on one hand it's embarrassing that i was
i was so wild and crazy
on the other hand
i made it through i'm still alive and i
was able to become successful
um
yeah part of me
really goes how did you get through that
how did you live through that i had some
pretty
crazy adventures shall we say i always
told everybody that
um
my life was so wild before elvira that
now that i was elvira my life was normal
and calm
and people always say really
yeah i think when you read the book
you'll see what i mean
yeah
you have this really interesting story
about meeting frank sinatra uh
yeah and i'm not so nice you know
meeting with frank sinatra and it struck
me that there's so many people
who are
uh even now just kind of obsessed with
meeting celebrities that they have seen
on screen or they listen to that they
love
is there anything that you would say to
young people that have kind of the stars
in their eyes about meeting people that
they
have an idea about because of the
product
but don't have an idea about
that person in real life
well i would say
more my message would be to the
celebrities themselves
try to remember what it was like for you
when you wanted to meet your idol and be
a nice freaking person
even if you
are sick of people approaching you and
all that just be
nice just say thank you
nice to meet you because i just remember
back on my
teenage years when i was chasing bands
around
and them just being kind to me
meant the world to me
you know i met a lot of uh jerks too and
it's just like couldn't you just say hi
or something hey i don't have time right
now but thanks i'm glad you're a fan
something
i mean i really think that is advice
that every celebrity needs to know and i
know it gets old it gets tiresome i
understand
but you don't have to be a jerk
true i like that absolutely you know you
people's dreams by doing that you really
do
you mentioned that
the alvaro brand might actually outlive
you can you can you talk about what you
think elvira's legacy will be
and what she has meant to you
yeah for me um
i think elvira will outlive me i think
the brand can keep going
i hate to break this to you but there's
no real santa claus but if there were
he's still been going
strong you know
for decades and decades
because he is um
kind of hooked to a
to a holiday
and i am also hooked to a holiday one
that's been growing leaps and bounds
since i started
and i think that elvira's legacy is
going to be
um
[Music]
continue way after
me
is it true that this halloween is going
to be the last time that you're going to
dress up as ovira i don't know if i want
to keep doing it when i'm 80 but then i
take a look at jane fonda and i go
maybe
you never know
i don't know i'm kind of ready to pack
it in now but
we'll see we'll see
who knows the halloween after you're
gonna be like why did i say i was gonna
hang it up we're gonna we're gonna bring
her back we're doing it again i say it
every decade
and then i change my mind
now you of course
um are so connected to halloween so
connected to
uh everything the dark horror movies do
you have
like a favorite horror movie of all time
like what what do you think is the
greatest
actual horror movie of all time oh my
gosh there's a lot of different
categories i mean i like the old cheesy
horror movies so
my taste in horror movies are a lot
different than than a lot of other
people's taste um i'd say for pure scare
factor
i still think the exorcist that movie
scared the living hell out of me and i
once saw it sitting right next to linda
blair and i couldn't even make it
through the movie i had to get up and
leave um
no
that movie just still still gets me um
older movies i still love house on
haunted hill with vincent price that
came out in the oh my gosh mid 50s
because it's very special to me because
that is a movie that got me hooked on
horror
second or third grade and i
it just blew me away and uh it started
my whole obsession with horror
so that movie has a very very special
place in my heart
do the movies of today hold a candle to
the classics
there are some really good movies out
there today uh
yeah and they do i think they're
there are some
[Music]
very very creative directors and writers
and producers out there doing horror
movies today i tend to go with the ones
that leave a little more to your
imagination
um instead of just packing in all the
cgi they can afford
you know movies like the witch which was
a while ago but
it didn't you didn't see anything that
really ever happened everything scary
was kind of in your mind
you know
a lot of movies like that blair witch
nothing really happened but it was damn
scary when it came out
you know and you didn't really see any
gruesome guts and blood and all that and
i don't mind
blood and guts i i actually like them
but
it's the way you do it and leave
something to the imagination tell a good
ghost story honestly that's
it's you know what you grew up with as a
kid sitting around a campfire and those
kind of stories still need to be told